[Music]
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex his first
year of marriage was filled with wedded
bliss so were strolling down memory lane
for a look at the moments that made us
swim it is beautiful as you remember
goodness it's amazing isn't it kicking
off our royal cuteness countdown
Meghan's reaction to seeing her wedding
dress for the first time since she and
Harry then I do on May 19th
2018 the work that they did here is just
so beautiful the moment was filmed for
HBO's documentary queen of the world and
came complete with this her warming
revelation there's a piece of did you
see it the piece of blue fabric that
stitched inside it was my something blue
it's my it's fabric from the dress today
we're on our first date and if m'aimes
wedding gowns don't melt your heart
megan and harry's PDA filled polo
tournament might do the trick
the Duke and his close friend nacho
figitus a LED team reaches to victory at
the 8th annual Santa Bali Polo Cup last
July
Megan who'd been looking on from her own
royal box presented the champions with
their trophy but she saved the grand
prize for her prince and that certainly
wasn't the couple's only swim worthy
moment of the day at number 6 Megan and
Harry's appearance at the 100th
anniversary of the Royal Air Force
[Music]
[Applause]
we quickly learned that the Sussex
couple is much more affectionate than
the Cambridge duo as they entered
Westminster Abbey
Megan holding Harry's arm while Will and
Kate kept their distance and the fields
didn't end there
Megan Harry graced us with plenty of
loving looks and affection up next Terri
and Megan's visit to the Jaffa Youth
Centre in Suffolk
you durable newlyweds couldn't get
enough of their eager fans or each other
this is a couple that just looks like
they genuinely enjoy each other's
company no matter what they're doing at
number four making an Harry's first
official royal tour of Australia New
Zealand Tonga and Fiji soon after
touching down the palace announced that
the Duchess was pregnant with their
first child and the cuteness ensued
Harry gushed it every opportunity he got
we also generally couldn't think of a
better place to announce the upcoming
baby I have been so proud to be able to
introduce my wife to you and we have
been so happy to be able to celebrate
the personal joy of our newest addition
with you all meanwhile Megan gave us our
first glimpse of what soon became her
iconic bump cradle you have a lot to be
proud of during the trip the Royals
shared several sweet moments under
umbrellas a number of romantic strolls
precious moments with kids
and can we talk about the way they look
at each other we all felt like
spectators in the Megan and Harry show
then there was Morocco Megan laughed
after her husband took a huge bite of
food and they giggled and cuddled while
visiting a secondary school their entire
fashion forward trip seemed like a dream
coming in at number two the royal
couple's surprise appearance at we'd a
2019 got to talk about that
crowd-pleasing cuddle
[Applause]
guys I am with you and we are with you
get to work but hands down the cutest
royal moment of 2019 Moses for just
hours after Harry became a dad he gushed
about his newborn son Archie the most
amazing experience I can ever possibly
imagine I'm so incredibly proud of my
wife and as every father and parent
would ever say you know you're your baby
is absolutely amazing but this little
thing is and if that doesn't have you
beaming right along with him here's the
momentary and Megan introduced their son
to the world
MAGIX it's pretty amazing
and I have the two best guys in the
world so I'm really
we just which is so thrilled to have joy
hashtag swoon there's no doubt this
couples love runs deep all the stars are
aligned everything was just perfect it
was this beautiful woman just sort of
literally tripped and fell into my life
I run into her life
[Music]